I know you're so tired you can't stop
yawning but has it sunk in yet when you
woke up this morning as Wimbledon
champion how did it feel yeah it was a
great great feeling
yeah only I've done is slept for an hour
and a half last night so it was pretty
pretty beat up one when I woke up but I
mean beautiful day to wake up as well
more than champion
I know life's probably been a bit of a
whirlwind doesn't it since that very
last point of the match did you manage
to celebrate the win I'm going out
tonight with all of my team we're all
going out to dinner together and
celebrate it I mean we had the champions
ball last night by the time we got done
with everything and got there it was
already about midnight and by the time
that finished it was about 2 o'clock so
he got home run 3 last night so it's
just yesterday was a long long day but
I'll have a chance to celebrate today
did you get any cool messages of
congratulation
yeah I mean from we are too many people
to to mention but I got message from the
Queen spoke David Beckham on the forum
this morning did you say well done yeah
but yeah I mean messages from just Lords
of people friends family people that
have been that coach me when I was
younger and had been part of the hole
right brilliant and your mum tweeted a
picture of her and efan Lendl I think
she said me and Dracula but he was
smiling in the picture which is quite
red did you have a little conversation
with him did he have a special message
for you afterwards no I mean I mean we
all speak he basically said you know
let's chat chat and a week but yeah I
mean I saw him last night he was the
champions ball and he yeah I mean he
just seemed he seemed really really
happy which was which is nice nice to
see when someone like him he's achieved
so much in his his own career that he
just he seemed genuinely pleased last
night and happy so it was good to slams
now I'm sure there's gonna be many more
I mean how much do you feel like a
weights been lifted off your
yeah I think I mean obviously yeah I
feel very relaxed today and there was a
huge release of tension and pressure
yesterday I'll feel that once they get
back on the match core I'll feel how
much more relaxed I am out there or
preparing for big events or whatever in
the future right now I mean I don't
really know but last year after the US
Open the next few tournaments I played I
just felt just a lot camera on the core
and just much much better about things
and what about the public support feed
this one will do it's been amazing
hasn't it this outpouring of love for
Andy Murray do that kind of overwhelm
you a little bit yeah well I mean the
thing is I mean it's unfortunate but I
can I can't read all the papers and I
can't watch the TV and I can't see
everything that goes on during the
tournament because I can afford to get
swept up or a sidetracked and not
concentrate on what I'm trying to do on
the court the atmosphere on the court
yesterday was unbelievable from the
first literally when we walked out there
right until the end was amazing and then
I saw some clips after the match of the
hill of Dunblane and Tower of London and
it was just yeah so many people behind
me but I I'm not I'm not allowed to see
all of those things when it's happening
absolutely and how do you top this I
mean would be world number one mean much
now I mean everyone would like to be in
that world number one but you know it's
such a hard thing to do and right now
I've hold two of the slams the final of
another one and Olympic gold and I'm
still not close to number one so it just
takes a whole year of just great play
and consistency and you know maybe one
day I'll get there your number one
source Andy what will you do now will
you have a bit of a rest we managed to
get to Dunblane where I hear there was
amazing
seeds last night according to your
granny I'm not 100% sure
no I mean I'll finish up with all the
stuff today and then I was planning on
going away on holiday for a week or so
I'm not sure exactly where I want to try
and try and get away but yeah it would
be nice to go back and see all my family
back up and up in Scotland
what I think the legacy might be for the
children picking up a tennis rackets on
the back of your winning Wimbledon I
mean I don't know I hope more kids start
playing I hope you know it's not as long
you know for another I hope I hope
that's not the case but look I'm sorry
but that isn't my job there's people
that you know have to put things in
place to give kids the opportunity to to
play and you know I hope yesterday has
done a small part to achieving you know
better results for British players in
the future
I'm sure you've inspired absolutely
millions of kids to pick up a racquet
and be well done brilliant again they
say much returning thanks